what's happening you bad [ __ ]
uncle Joey's bad [ __ ] in full effect
you guys like Joey where the [ __ ] you've
been I've been busy shooting specials
writing jokes [ __ ] video games mafia
3 whatever the [ __ ] you need uncle
Joey's here it's a beautiful day to be
alive it's Monday October what [ __ ]
1760 who gives a [ __ ] you're swingin
dick and giving out popsicles you
understand me that's all that matters
it's been rough lately everything's
beautiful I'm back like [ __ ] herpes
my back is still a little out of whack
I'm gonna go to jujitsu today but I
think I'm back there [ __ ] Wednesday I
went to the chiropractor and the doctor
this morning I got a meeting in a little
wild come on we got pictures I got
pictures we're doing some big [ __ ]
shitty of it don't matter it's all about
the reefer [ __ ]
because without the Reaper
you gotta understand me you got no focus
you got oh gods
you're dead kid what the [ __ ] am I gonna
do with my life thank God uncle Joey
showed up with a [ __ ] pipe in a
[ __ ] oh that today we got Paris oh
Jesus with the [ __ ] people smoke when
they [ __ ] they shoot themselves in Paris
I got the beautiful [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
brain [ __ ] freeze I'm loving it I'm
back I'm rested Chicago this special I
love you [ __ ] in Chicago more
than you know you guys know that's why I
did the special I talked to my brother
Sebastian he's like [ __ ] to rock him out
let's do this [ __ ] tremendous I mean
Chicago from the hot beef to the [ __ ]
beautiful oatmeal with coconut milk I
mean I loved everything about it too
[ __ ] every time I go to Chicago and I
have a great [ __ ] time Chicago Rose
month I don't know what to say about
that [ __ ] Club it's just tremendous
that people take the ride first show was
a little cool sequence and we taped on
Saturday but the second show was [ __ ]
those people didn't give a [ __ ] and
guess what
near that I
this brain freeze is tremendous plus I
got some [ __ ] star dust inside I got
like eight different [ __ ] weeds I got
more weed than the [ __ ] Weed Man this
week ain't doing dick I ain't doing
stand-up I'm taking a week off I'm
writing the last chapter in the [ __ ]
books where we can [ __ ] get this [ __ ]
out there me and my man Gordon Warnock I
love my main [ __ ] agent and
besides that that said it's just want to
be one of those weeks I'm gonna go for a
walk today burn some [ __ ] calories
you know loosen up the muscles in the
back tomorrow I got some [ __ ] to never
got the podcast on 8:00 we got the
podcast Wednesday night we're coming at
you for more [ __ ] directions
I love it I love getting together which
I missed you [ __ ] I really
didn't miss you see you in a hotel room
when you go outside you got a smoke
[ __ ] joint yeah don't get the smokey
effect when I come at you I come at you
you know how we do it
don't forget tonight 8 o'clock podcast
don't forget two more weeks
tremendous word [ __ ] Vegas for
Halloween weekend at the South Point
don't forget two more weeks after that
word at Boston and Fox will Country Club
you know it's on a month it's on and
running [ __ ] and besides that I'm
feeling good I got you guys checking on
me you know when I got you guys I can't
[ __ ] loose with you guys in my corner
come on this is why I got up to write to
be sharp to be a better [ __ ]
individual for you [ __ ] we have
a great podcast tonight never fear Uncle
Joe we say [ __ ] suckers but for the rest
of the day
it's reefer a few meetings a few phone
calls
can't explain to you what an honor was
shooting the special this week it was
all because of you guys listen until you
guys started couple along I was fighting
for my [ __ ] life you understand me
these guys didn't [ __ ] wanna run with
Uncle Joe even though I was strong he
that these [ __ ] all night that
we just put me on the back burner put me
on the back my like the Diaz brothers
but all sudden we started [ __ ]
ripping these [ __ ] apart and
guess what there's a new [ __ ]
sheriff in town now [ __ ] these little
guys that they'd knock knock bumping
jokes that could suck my dick you got to
be dangerous to be a [ __ ] community
that would be dangerous to be a [ __ ]
artist and that's what we're gonna try
to be from now on especially with that
that's what crew I ain't [ __ ] around
no more do I one foot in the grave on a
banana peel I [ __ ] the [ __ ] than that
he'll go to an improv you see a picture
mayonnaise commie clubs they are not for
me but guess what now they have no
[ __ ] choice you understand because
we're gonna give him the [ __ ] choice
then we're bad [ __ ] the church
comes in heavy remember I'm with you
you're with me and they want to be with
us but they can't because they have that
[ __ ] real we spot them as they show
up a little faith [ __ ] glasses the
[ __ ] out of here the church is the
church [ __ ]
we don't [ __ ] around so always remember
that we're straight up with salad
we don't [ __ ] lie we don't when I
fake people we come at [ __ ] from the
[ __ ] straight up no sunglasses no
nothing will coming at you like
something a realist and that's it and
that's that I'm strong gonna [ __ ]
kill so I'm gonna make a little [ __ ]
protein shake and I said if I don't get
to I'll check with you [ __ ]
later it's not it's not a drizzle out
here I'll see you guys up about 7:30 la
time for the church or what's happening
now right stay black Ramon cool Joey
lotion I'm [ __ ] storm - hang on a lot
of you go
this [ __ ] brain freezes off the chart
if you got a minute
but reneus brain freeze - uncle Joey
sent you